My name is Starr. Two Rs.
Daddy named me that.
Garden Heights. Mom and Daddy say our life is here
cause our people are here.
The high school is where you go to get drunk, high
or pregnant. We don't go there.
Williamson is another world, so when I'm here
I'm Starr version 2.
Until the weekend comes around.
What's up? Where you've been?
- Man, I know you been hanging with all the white kids. - Shut up!
Out. Of. The car.
- Yo, Starr, you okay? - Go back where he told you. Khalil, I'm not playing, go back where...
Today Garden Heights is reeling after the shooting of a
seventeen-year-old black teenager by a white police officer.
Violence.
Brutality.
We live in a complicated world.
It doesn't seem that complicated to me.
It's about more than just Khalil.
It's about black people, poor people, everybody at the bottom.
I need to speak for him.
When you ready to talk, you talk.
I never let nobody make you be quiet.
I ain't named you Starr by accident.